hey how's going bros my name is peter
pan we're playing until dawn oh my god
this game looks amazing we just left off
this guy just did like an analysis on us
asking us questions and I think the game
will change depending on how we answer
all right I'm gonna try my best to make
good decisions all right I don't usually
make good decisions so this is a problem
I can't help it it's not my fault Peter
Stormare
he's a Swedish actor holy [ __ ] how did I
not recognize I knew I knew when I saw
him I knew come on can't believe I've
been this opposed to Peter Stormare how
would you say that in English Peter
stormer how would you say my name Felix
Kjellberg Felix celli
all right no one cares this is great I
can't believe how is year anniversary of
the dreadful tragedy that took place one
year ago tonight the Washington girls
left the safety of their parents lodge
and headed out into this foul play not
officially no there is one individual
we're considering as a person of
interest but his whereabouts are
currently unknown he has an interesting
history with the Washington family he
had warned them against pursuing their
construction project and claimed the
land was sacred to his forefathers you
know there is still the Orion my
officers did search the grounds but
themselves couldn't have made it that
far something about that mountain seems
to breed tragic events you know Marty
thank you for joining us
over Washington's tonight their son Josh
on this the anniversary of the
mysterious disappearance of Hannah all
right let's do that again
you see a youtuber all right well hello
friends and fans yeah it's beyond
awesome to have you guys all back this
year first off I gotta say I'm super
excited to welcome all my pals back to
the annual Blackwood winter getaway let
me just let you know let's take a moment
to address the elephant in the room for
a second I know you're all probably
worried about me
and I know it's gonna be tough on all of
us going back after what happened last
year so they keeping it up anyway I just
want you all to know it means
it means so much to me that we're doing
this and I know it would mean so much to
Hanna and Beth that were we're all still
here together
[ __ ] yeah of them I really want to spend
some quality time with each and every
one of you and just share some moments
that we'll never forget her for the sake
of my so it was sisters okay you know
okay so let's party like we're [ __ ]
porn stars okay make this one trip we
will never forget all right
yes they really become more and more
realistic every year not every year but
you can really tell the difference
I'm impressed it looks so cool
[Music]
[Applause]
my god mine got so pretty
[Music]
Chappell
Blackwood Pines I rather right here
begins so pumped it seemed like it will
heavily interesting story I did
something will be scary you know I'm
just going to find out
I'm glad the bus to stop it right now
momento my 10 hours until dawn that's
awesome okay here we go
he's already Jesus Christ that guy never
leaves with his machete huh Sam Hannah's
best friend diligent considerate and
adventurous well where was she when she
died so this is our protagonist huh
totally nine paths to cable car station
nine Zahra - why are we going to the
cable this is such a creepy Pat who the
[ __ ] would walk here alone okay I can
move the camera now that's that's cool
oh my god
no [ __ ] way I would enter anything
looking like this is this open okay
alright we need to look around that
looks like a glint the gate what is the
same
thank you character traits what what is
old this okay we'll check that in a bit
right what the hell the gates busted
climb over okay no big deal left side
looks good let's do that
alright look yet quick one hey I'm ready
jump she's crazy
yeah damn it let's do it again
I like to get the option at least you
want to be a hardcore pro player I'm
just kidding obviously
alright there we go there we go no big
deal no big deal at all like ia just
leave this sign like that for the guests
just climb over no big deal I will get
down
he's poking at me he isn't me all right
well we keep going I know you can do a
lot of searching in the game for like
unlockables and [ __ ] oh don't oh don't
move the controller let me give me
another try
that's awesome so like yeah I'm not
moving so you will have to not move the
controller probably when you're hiding
in [ __ ] that's really creepy
awesome man PlayStation really has the
best exclusive titles I gotta say I like
how they're using all the functions and
[ __ ] so far like I think some of the
most successful series that I had are
all PlayStation titles like beyond two
souls Last of Us
heavy rain Kathryn okay so here's some
history indeed indeed that's too hard
for me to say people and butterfly
prophy prophecies tribes who once lived
in these mountains believe that
butterflies carry dreams and prophecies
of possible futures that's kind of cool
the color of the butterfly indicated the
nature of the prophecy Beth black
butterflied prophets sighs dead dreamers
death see I can say fancy words
prophesize danger red butterflies
dangerous events loss brown butterflies
foretold tragedy affecting friends so
I'm sure that's gonna happen or is there
more
yellow is vision and help how do I
scroll down there we go okay sorry and
then white our dreams of luck okay
that's good to know
I'm sure they're gonna appear oh my god
you can discover totem artifacts see
that's what I was talking about why do I
keep clicking that button Jesus Christ
how do I pick it up then there you go
I like mine I like my nail polish hey I
can appreciate nail polish all right
is that a [ __ ] totem Jesus Christ
okay whether or not the prophecies come
true it's up to you that's awesome okay
we got something over here
who leaves their phone out like that in
a backpack come on this has to be a trap
obviously I'm gonna snoop this is Chris
okay we got chris has a crush on Ashley
yep
methodical protective humorous that face
my god I'm sorry are you my secretary
was buzzing cool well thanks for letting
me know I I can take it from here
hmm
one you left your phone out like it was
a treasure oh so I found something kind
of amazing
I'm not gonna tell you you gotta see for
yourself
come on it's this way we're right around
here gonna blow your mind game is [ __ ]
awesome
should we investigate what this is might
as well some clues maybe he comes up
here
no one comes up here this does not seem
safe Chris no don't - Dom what the hell
is a shooting range doing at the base of
ski lodge dude have you ever met Josh's
dad yeah these these like Grizzly Adams
or something try alright here goes this
is my chance to look good in front of
the girl do I get to play as Chris now -
shoot these Lori how does it work yep
kill that bag and I got the game of an
angel should join a quickscope clan or
some [ __ ] look at things she's tiny huh
let's rag girl no I'm not shooting the
squirrel [ __ ] you I'm not shooting a
swirl
[Music]
nice shot
guys just got Zach white butter come on
was that tragedy or loss no it's too
soon okay we did it how are you brother
what are you resting in this game's on
fire it's it's really interesting
that's weird doors locked yeah Josh
wanted us to keep it locked keep people
out he said that what people I don't
know he said they found people sleeping
in the station with time it's creepy and
maybe people being looking for the
police and [ __ ] Jesus
so where's the skis what is this oh I'm
controlling this guy its lap that is
sorry Oh awkward I thought the car was
closer guess we gotta wait I'm starting
to get the appeal of killing time at the
shooting range how long is this gonna
take
it's a big mountain we have to wait for
it you're pretty poem the sleeping giant
so we have to look around Wellington
please to set up house no matter how
rich you are
Hotel and sanatorium
or healthy body and mind great it sounds
like it's coming closer let's look a
little from Lauren Saturn jacuzzi
I was they check on our girl bad bad bad
the depth at Bell God is he dead to joke
about everything
oh my god he's me I'm coming here we go
right venture begins you know getting
everyone together on the anniversary and
we Josh seem really pumped about us all
doing something Denis yeah no he
definitely did I haven't seen him so
excited about something in forever good
good I bet that thing is gonna break
down no it was a good idea well here are
we thanks bro
good talk you know what let's just let's
just stop talking about what happened
and enjoy the trip you're right
you know how Josh and I met
third grade Josh sat in the back of the
room i sat in the front we didn't even
know each other existed but the kid
sitting next to Josh started strapped
snapping the training bra on the girl in
front of him so the teacher made him
move to the front where I was and next
to Josh that's how we met
oh my god it's a heart
amazing and Jeanie Simmons hit you
really knows you could be riding in this
cable car alone right now or talking to
some other butterfly family boom
butterfly oh my god is it echoing in
here Jesus Christ nice
we're entering I was a black Blackwood
Pines wayward Pines
we got a new character yes
Mike's new girlfriend she's confident
trusting irreverent great
I'm to me great oh my god
I'm playing as hard Jesus guys I feel
like we're all just oh Jesus Christ
over here are you guys having a really
weird stroke we're stuck in this stupid
thing can you please let us out pretty
please another ten minutes in there and
I would have chewed off my own leg
--look got a lot of meat on my bones
it's all muscle down here yeah hey I'm
just doing like Sam Tommy other people's
private thoughts of my own do not be a
jerk my goodness
butterfly effect that's that someone has
a little crush on our good friend and
dear class president Michael Monroe
crass and what kind of sizzling erotica
might our Jessica be capable of
imagining I wonder
I feel like give that back is more
cliche so I'm just gonna go with a more
cliche give that back you tool to one
die that's my model oh you're such an
idiot
maybe nosy Nancy shouldn't go nosing
around in other people's nostrils do
that rule you can tell us totally keep
secrets whatever you'll figure it out
eventually
alright alright let's just get up to the
lodge or it's getting tired of always a
major chunk you guys go ahead I'm just
gonna wait here for a bit see who else
is coming
you mean like what I mean you know
whoever
Sam
did you use view I mean holy cow I
recognize the actors now isn't she from
that One Tree Hill show your character
Emily
Mike's ex intelligent resourceful
persuasive old trades of Asian people
sorry I had to say it
Matt Emily's new boyfriend motivated
ambitious and active active right I've
had Iraq boy when you need one where are
we now I'm well confused
oh Jesus perfect
what a mic you [ __ ] intelligent yeah
right driven and persuasive Michael I
almost clocked you just now nice Michael
you're a jerk cool guys we're all
friends here right no need for violence
just a little harmless fun
well up in the woods spooky things the
spirit of things seriously what's wrong
with you just trying to lighten the mood
M don't be like that
like what the way you're being you
always get like this back off Mike all
right I got a step up Michael you got a
step off Emily and I are together now
and that's just the way it is not gonna
tell you again
do we understand each other well I
thought maybe we can weave past all this
buds but yeah fine Mike no no no no it's
totally cool I'm just gonna head down
the road the all mature and [ __ ] by
myself over here peace I think you got
the message yes yes right choice right
[ __ ] now
crap what hey could you take these the
rest of the way the bags yeah all the
bags of why I need to go find Sam girls
okay
sorry I just I really need to go find
her I totally forgot I needed to talk to
her before we get all the way up there
that's really can't wait we're almost
there it's important not please
fine
all right fine but so important I guess
I can pack horse at the rest of the way
but you only one excuse me
well the more even at least I'll think
about it
just be careful see you up there sweetie
thank you I'm not sure if I ship them
I'm not sure okay I'm guessing we're
gonna go to a new character again
or I'm gonna to play as him no new
character right we're gonna make it up
to the launch come on Ashley has a crush
on Chris and Chris sit inquisitive
forthright and academic who's Chris I'm
so lost in all the characters how here
Chris of course I can look around with
this and having a bat bat bat bat bat
and I'm gonna bet that with that pastor
father to you what daddy I hello
somebody's getting a little friendly
[ __ ] whoa check the expiration date on
their big breakup
what the [ __ ] dick [ __ ] mother ding
[ __ ] didn't mean to scare you sort of
scare me but not like for real hey man
sorry it's okay it's fine what are you
looking at see anything juice without it
yeah let me check it out what should I
do
um it's busted
yeah it's kind of busted it's not it's
not like really interesting I just yeah
that sounded convincing for real yeah
but I could find like a cold bear
chowing down on a fox or something sure
of yourself
is it ever just nothing with him ever I
don't know I damn it oh [ __ ]
we didn't do anything
we're just hogging oh you're so jealous
should we check our phone doesn't seem
like a place to read a book
[Music]
we're joints do a stuff of young rebel
girl half of the surrender to the
strapping military guard come to take me
into custody you're gonna grab a
snowball I don't know Beach Oh get Rick
scrub music oh this guy's getting fun
yeah
oh snap yeah bird is done look at that
yet
[Music]
boom-shaka-laka
I got him three times that of Jesus
Christ get on my level [ __ ] sometimes
doing nothing is too right does that
mean yeah well I get a bird not an
[ __ ]
interesting
the game didn't lie huh so-called Oh God
so did I go down I don't think all right
all right
my my so are we calling it my favorite
then you're worthy opponent Miss Jessica
the snowball Queen okay that sounds
vaguely dirty my lady
what am I gonna get Wow I can think of
it least one thing yeah well you'll have
to wait until later we should get up to
the lodge yeah it's so nice out here
though Freddy a breath-taking I mean I
could stay out here for pretty much ever
provided I was making out with you the
whole time
just anything else oh no we might freeze
to death somewhere in between those
quotes
choo-choo [ __ ] alright alright
alright
the next lift is going why don't we all
just go together like why don't we all
have to go at separate times I don't
understand every single person just
[ __ ] cried my god be at that P at the
store man who like it hey son okay seems
you're hard to scratch the surface let's
go
alright Iraq this time we're going to
try to understand the root of your
anxiety sounds good pick up that book
turn the pages you will see a set of
pictures and symbols I want you to
identify which image it's gonna be a
Rorschach test the most anxious sounds
like it yeah no all right which one
makes me more anxious women or men
that's a deep question I don't know it
depends on the scenario right hey I'm a
player look
[Music]
crowds or planes crowds some worried
about getting recognized or like swamped
in a crowd
I hate fear Heights or drowning
definitely drowning rats or snakes
snakes scares me more feel free to
answer your breath as well he's just
taking notes guns are knives knives this
is really cool cockroaches are snakes
I feel like snakes scare me more because
they can be venomous cockroaches are
just kind of gross well I'm glad you're
taking notes clowns or scarecrows I
never really seen a scarecrow in real
life so it's kind of hard for me to
relate to something feel like clowns are
scary
Gor
definitely oh my god why did I start
with you
so sorry you're doing very well
don't be love thank you
try to you guys relax
the more you rely on your instincts the
more honest your answers will be in the
more enlightening you will find this
experience thank you okay I just went
with that I'm just trying to be like
he's saying Gor okay next one clowns or
zombies I don't know
concept of zombies is scarier to me than
clowns Gore definitely I'm very
persistent in the gore part this is very
interesting
yep thank you for answering so diligent
spiders yummy an awful Sun combination
sounds like a good Friday night he's so
creepy such a good actor
well I'm afraid once again we're out of
time
I promise we'll talk again very soon
just want to pinch his cheeks
all right breasts I'm gonna have to end
that episode there I will see you again
with another episode tomorrow thank you
so much for all the support I think
there's gonna be an amazing series I'm
so excited
thank you and as always stay awesome
bros